how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
relating to the MCU and today we have a
leaked video from the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier series now this is a
fight scene and it does involve the new
Captain America and Bucky it's not very
spoilery it doesn't really give away too
much but it is a scene from the show so
if you are trying to avoid all spoilers
you may want to click away if you're
still with me let's go ahead and watch
this leaked video so there are actually
five major points to take away from this
this scene although short does actually
reveal a lot so we'll go ahead and go
over each of these five things and talk
about how this is also connected to the
black widow movie if you're new be sure
to subscribe to stay up to date on all
MCU news and so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or ps4 all you have to do is be
subscribed like the video and comment
down below about the video so the first
thing that we notice about this leaked
footage is of course the new Captain
America but he's also fighting alongside
Bucky so we have the new Captain America
and the Winter Soldier fighting together
not against each other in the comics
u.s. agent John Walker who becomes
Captain America instead of Sam isn't
exactly the best guy and he's more of an
evil Captain America than an actual good
guy but as we see here he's actually
doing some good he's helping Bucky
rescue people who have seemingly been
kidnapped and thrown in the back of his
van we can see the new Captain America
fight off a bunch of bad guys while
Bucky breaks the people out of the back
of the van now there was a recent leak
that said John Walker u.s. agent is
actually a really good guy and he wants
to be a very good Captain America he
looked up to Steve Rogers and he wants
to be just like him and make the people
and Steve proud but when the government
gives him the Super Soldier Serum they
used the serum to control his mind and
we'll talk about that in a bit and that
leads us to the second thing that you
probably noticed about this video and
that is the fact that there is no Sam
there is no Falcon in this scene so
unless Sam is actually doing a different
objective on the same mission he's not
involved in this and it may because he's
decided to stay out of the government
business
since for whatever reason he is not the
current Captain America it's John Walker
number three the choreography of this
scene is actually quite good it's a very
good fight scene but this actually does
reveal a lot about John Walker as we see
him fight we noticed he's not a very
skilled fighter he's actually kind of a
sloppy fighter and kind of a brawler
when he fights we can see him swing and
miss punches and we can also see them
hit him several times and he misses his
punches several times as well so we can
see that as he fights he's kind of a
scrappy fighter and this is very
different than Steve Rogers he was more
of a calculated and very skilled
hand-to-hand combat fighter but luckily
as we can tell he does have the Super
Soldier Serum which is the fourth a big
reveal about this it was uncertain on
whether or not the new Captain America
would get some type of Super Soldier
Serum but as we can tell from this video
he definitely does because you can tell
how strong he is in this video he's able
to take a lot of punches and not really
be that affected by it and we can see
that when he hits people they kind of go
flying and at one point in time he does
throw somebody a pretty far away so he
does have the serum which is really good
because his fighting skills aren't
really up to par with the old Captain
America's which leads us to point number
five which is kind of a big deal and
that is that he doesn't really know how
Captain America used to fight this is a
pretty big deal and it's very revealing
because in the comics taskmaster is
actually the person who trains John
Walker and taskmaster has the ability to
be able to mimic anyone's fighting style
perfectly so taskmaster knew how Captain
America fought and he taught us agent
John Walker how to fight just like
Captain America so clearly by looking at
John Walker in this scene he does not
know how to fight like Captain America
which means that he has not been trained
by taskmaster but that doesn't mean that
he won't someday it's been reported by
Daniel RPK that the Thunderbolts are
going to be introduced in the Falcon in
the Winter Soldier series and it's
expected that Thunderbolt Ross is going
to be the person in charge of course of
becoming the Red Hulk but also
recruiting taskmaster for the
Thunderbolts as well from what we know
right now Thunderbolt Ross is going to
be the person who decides that US agent
John Walker is Captain America and if
taskmaster is working for him then he
can have taskmaster train John Walker
how to fight like Captain America and
going back to the super serum part we
have seen a leak that says that the
serum does allow Thunderbolt Ross to
control John Walker so even though he's
a good guy he could be turned by
Thunderball Ross because he has the
serum inside of him so he himself could
even go on to become a member of the
Thunderbolts because we do know that
Falcon is eventually going to take on
the mantle of Captain America what's
really interesting about this is that we
know Thunderbolt Ross is going to be in
the Black Widow movie we know the movie
takes place right after Captain America
Civil War where Black Widow is wanted
and Thunderbolt Ross is going to be the
person looking for her so given all
these connections it is very possible
that taskmaster actually works for
Thunderbolt Ross something that will
most likely be revealed in the Black
Widow movie and a sixth bonus thing to
note is that John Walker actually
doesn't have the shield in this video it
could be possible that he just lost it
at some point in time during this
mission that him and Bucky are on or it
could be that Falcon since he's not
there hasn't actually given in the
shield yet because we have seen some
leaked photos of him with the shield and
it is clearly the same shield that Steve
gave Sam at the end of Avengers endgame
so leave your thoughts on this leaked
video in the comments down below and let
me know if I may have missed anything
that you picked up on don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you can
stay up to date on MCU news and be sure
to check out one of my latest videos on
a Hulk vs. Wolverine film that could
come to the MCU as always thank you all
so much for watching
woof woof